this kid is it once a lifetime help I  became a person that I didn't really  know it's unfortunate my name have to  keep coming up with certain things and I  have anything to do with I can either  sell that money change me any time they  have is that's a recipe for disaster and  it led me down a dark road  graphic details about how Michael Vick's  Virginia property was the headquarters  of bad news kennels that dogs were  raised there to fight the dogs were  executed the dogs that did not fight it  was wrong  criminally wrong but he operated in a  culture in which that was not all that  rare  he remains in the top five most hated  athletes of all time people equate what  he did with child abuse I try not to  dwell on people's thoughts in their  perception because I know I can't change  that I understand it I don't blame  do believe that everybody's entitled to  a second chance